[موسيقى]
الساعه تشير الى السادسه صباحا خيوط الشمس
تداعب شواطئ راس الحد فايل الحربي يستعد
لخوض عباد البحر مبكرا
منذ نشاته لا يعرف سوى صيد الاسماك كمصدر
دخل الله
من اهلنا يعني اهالينا قبل يعني عايشين من
البحر
الا هي الصيد
انا اشتغلت بديت اول ما بديت عمري عشر
سنوات
ضليت اطلع مع والدي اطلع مع اخواني ونتعلم
معاهم درجه درجه
هذا المكان يشهد اول شروق الشمس في الشرق
الاوسط فهو يقع بين ثلاثه مواقع بحريه بحر
عمان وبحر العرب والمحيط الهندي
[موسيقى]
يبدو متفائلا هذا الصباح الدلافين ترافق
قريبه الصغير الطعم هو الاخر جاهزا
لاستقبال الاسماك الحظ بدا يبتسم لهذا
الصياد 30 بعد صبري عده ساعات في عرض
البحر
[موسيقى]
بدونك نهائيا بصراحه البحر يعني
شيء بالنسبه لي يعني شيء كبير جدا
حلوه جدا
اكثر من تسعه واربعين الفصياد عماني في
السلطنه بحسب الارقام الحكوميه بالاضافه
الى وجود اسطول كبير للصيد حيث يبلغ عدد
سفن وقوارب الصيد اكثر من 14,000 1900
سفينه واستدع من حكومي مستمر لهذا القطاع
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من ولايه الصور
العربيه